small businesses are facing obviously
unprecedented times we've been giving
messages of hope to individual families
for a week all the Remzi personalities
have it occurs to me that there's some
basic things that your business folks
need to hear number one
leaders during this time are there
fashioned you you are the steel laying
in the fire becoming a sword right now
some of you this is a your you are
getting good at leadership and the and
this is going to fast forward your
leadership the the sharpness of the
metal in your leadership you're going to
learn how to love your people deeper
than you ever have you're gonna learn
how to fight more than you've ever
fought you're gonna learn how to scratch
and pivot and take something to the
market quickly and easily from work at
home people you know I've got all of our
thousand people at home just about I
mean we've got fifteen of us down here
doing the show but everybody else is at
home and you don't know how to pivot and
create products in that environment and
deliver sales in that environment and it
you are stretching and it's unbelievably
stressful it's it's fatiguing but the
great news is you will never again
return to the same shape you were before
because you're going to be bigger think
bigger and be better than you've ever
been as a result of this that's the only
good news of all this bullcrap or going
through Dave I want to talk to the
leader listening right now go nuts great
for people whose business is gonna
survive this we're having to shut this
thing down and I want you to hear you
know as business owners as leaders we
get so amesh in our identity being our
business here's the thing you might lose
your business you might lose some team
members your business may look very
different on the other side of this
but you're still gonna be here and
you're gonna figure out how to relaunch
how to rebuild how to come back stronger
and so I I just want to give people
permission who are going I lost my baby
it's all over I'm nothing
I don't have any purpose anymore no your
purpose is who you are and what God puts
you on this planet to do and there's a
there's a big problem with the thing
that you've been building that thing on
top of and your platforms been shaken
but just like when a tornado comes
through a city and knocks down houses
the city doesn't go well it's just not
putting more houses back there you're
gonna come back you know I want to talk
to the business leader Dave and Daniel
who they are facing right now the
potential of having to shut it down they
are running out of cash we've had a
couple calls like that the shower what
do I do and I think that there's two
things I want you to know number one
this is a complex time and the best way
to solve complexity is with simplicity
and it looks really gnarly but you have
got to kind of put everything out on the
whiteboard everything on the table and
say what can I control and now I'm gonna
have to look at the most urgent
decisions to protect the business and
this involves sometimes letting people
go and that is gut wrenching it is not
easy it's the hardest part of leadership
but don't get sucked into the temptation
this is the second piece of taking alone
that could hurt you a long term and
actually threaten the business viability
long term as opposed to making the tough
decisions by communicating with the team
and saying here's what we know now
here's what we have to do now and and
maybe taking a hit to your heart by
having to make some tough decisions
about your people in order to put you in
a position where you can reopen and I
think that's that's a really tough
situation right now over communicate to
the team you know they're treat them
like adults that's right they want to
know dollars on everything that's going
on the real that's right really what's
going on don't you know they're not
children you don't have to hide news
from them that's right then the second
thing is you will be amazed at
at some of your team at how unbelievably
generous they are if you over
communicate with them in our case we've
already told our team the first thing
that will happen is the operating board
which there's 16 of us that are at that
top echelon of the thousand in terms of
our leadership we will go without pay a
month that'll be the first thing we'll
do we get paid off the bottom line
anyway which by definition we would be
going without papers there be no profits
so but we're not you know we're just
gonna set that aside then the second
thing we would go to is is that rather
than lay people off here what we but
we've proposed is and you can design
your own thing but we just told our team
what we're gonna do ahead of time if it
gets to that we'll have them all skip a
check and keep working and I'd rather do
that rather everybody feel a little pain
then then a few of them feel a ton of
pain because we don't have anybody here
that we don't need I would have already
gotten rid of them if we didn't need
them you know so we that that's I
wouldn't hire them if I didn't need them
so and we don't have anybody here we
don't like as we already would have
gotten rid of them if that was a case
and so that kind of a thing so everybody
that's here we want here and so we're
gonna you know we'll but you just assign
out and we just told everybody and you
know what their response was yeah yeah I
didn't have anybody go oh no I would
rather you lay off a hundred and
although the rest of us get our full pay
not a single person said anything like
that as a matter of fact several other
layers of leadership started coming to
us saying if it'll help we'll skip a
check and we didn't even ask them to do
that didn't even hint that they should
but the team will all jump in together
and surprise you with their generosity
for each other to get you through your
cash crunch if your faith if you get to
that point we are not to that point but
we're already emotionally preparing
everyone not just not just the owners
well a team will act like family if you
treat them like family and as a family
hey we're gonna win together we're gonna
lose together but we're not going to cut
one of our members off and say well
sucks for them at least I'm still here
that's not how we do it here and that's
now how your business to do it
I want business owners to think about
you know we have the four walls and
personal
finance and business is a little bit
different but you got to be thinking
about how can I keep revenue going
that's the oxygen to your business how
can I keep the team morale up how can I
communicate with the team and how do we
get through this with the entire team to
Dave's point I want you thinking about
your critical expenses some of your
expenses are nice to have some of them
are long-term investments maybe you
don't put all those expenses out there
right now tighten your belt a little bit
on the expenses and then how can you
show up for your customers not
necessarily just with a sales offer but
how can you give them something that's
valuable how can you encourage them how
can you adapt your product or service to
add value today that builds customer
loyalty that later is going to turn it
your customers are not going to forget
who you are for them in this season and
over the course of a year there'll be a
point where that stuff will monetize you
focus on those four things you're most
likely going to get through this
unscathed yeah and I got to tell you
those of you that think you're running
eight weeks out I you know I'm just
economist and weather forecasters the
only two people that can be wrong all
the time keep their jobs so just put me
in that bucket okay all right but but I
cannot grasp how our economic way of
life would survive another four weeks in
May with a shutdown I can I don't think
it's economically possible I have no
idea what that means with the virus
other than thank God it'll be summer and
my understanding from some medical
people is that the the virus doesn't
like heat and like a lot of you know
colds and viruses or wintertime animals
right and they die in the summer so the
heat in the summer will help us with
that hopefully but anyway regardless of
that regardless of the medical side of
the actual curve or whatever you want to
project mathematically economically the
chances of this economy and our way of
life surviving an additional four weeks
of shutdown into May so I'm not planning
that because I don't I can't foresee it
actually working so I'm planning other
stuff at that point I think you're going
to have all kinds of political upheaval
all kinds of unrest like you've never
seen in America if you if we do that in
May so that's just an opinion and it's
worth what you paid for it so I'm not
I'm saying make it through April and
you're probably gonna be okay that's my
point
I don't know when in April but you know
if you can make it through the end of
April and with your plans you're gonna
be okay